Bonjour internet,
Il y a deux jours, j'ai sorti une vidéo sur les techniques de drague d'un certain William !
et ça a fait polémique chez certaines personnes.
J'avais envie de vous en parler,
et puis, on est sur Internet, voilà
, je peux prendre la parole quand je veux sur ma chaîne YouTube
pour échanger avec vous, alors j'en profite.
Il y a un peu plus d'une semaine, j'ai découvert la chaîne de William,
et j'ai beaucoup ris
en écoutant ses conseils de drague,
"prendre des douches", "accoster dix femmes par jour",
"les femmes aiment les chemises de couleurs vives"...
Je me dis qu'il y a matière à faire une vidéo marrante
en se moquant gentiment sans être méchant.
Et puis quelques jours plus tard, William renomme toutes ses vidéos en :
"Première chaîne de séduction humoristique"
Alors là je me dis : "Il a du recul",
je vais écrire une vidéo.
Alors l'angle de ma vidéo était très simple :
Première partie, je montre les conseils de drague de Willliam
Et deuxième partie, j'applique les conseils de William dans la vraie vie pour voir si ça marche.
Je tourne, je monte et je mets en ligne,
et là,
la polémique arrive.
Ça dit en gros :
J'avais écrit ma vidéo de la même manière que
j'avais écrit le clash des Lopez, Sofiane et Nabilla, le clash de Cortex
Alors pourquoi cette fois-ci ça polémique ?
Pour plusieurs raisons, mais une principalement.
Vous savez très bien où je veux en venir.
Du coup, là, les critiques sur des mecs extrêmes,
violents, qui cherchent à faire le buzz, ça marche ;
sur quelqu'un de gentil, ça ressemble à de l'acharnement.
J'ai jamais voulu être insultant envers William,
je voulais juste me moquer gentiment de ses techniques de drague.
Mais visiblement,
j'ai foiré.
Il y a un point assez important,
je n'aime pas les dragueurs professionnels,
les "pick up artists", ça a plein de noms
les mecs qui veulent prouver qu'ils peuvent choper des numéros dans la rue,
qu'ils peuvent embrasser des inconnues
qui vous expliquent comment manipuler les filles pour coucher avec...
Leur but c'est clairement de coucher avec le plus
de filles possibles et je comprends pas pourquoi
c'est toléré chez les mecs
mais si une fille fait une vidéo où elle embrasse
des inconnus dans la rue, elle va se faire traiter de trainée.
Voilà, c'est un truc que j'aime pas du tout,
et moi j'ai rangé William dans le même sac
que ces gens là, alors qu'il est vraiment gentil.
Il est tellement respectueux qu'il propose quand même
deux mètres de distance quand il parle à une fille.
L'angle de la vidéo a aussi joué sur la polémique.
Alors mon angle, c'était d'appliquer les conseils de drague
de William dans la vie, sauf qu'en fait,
ça ne dure qu'une minute dans la vidéo,
c'est à la fin en plus, et du coup,
80% de la vidéo, c'est moi qui me moque des techniques de drague de William,
et ça peut ressembler à de l'acharnement personnel.
Un dernier point, c'est mon état d'esprit quand je fais une vidéo.
Un état d'esprit de fdp!
Alors je vous explique,
quand je fais une vidéo, quand j'écris,
je fais comme si je n'avais aucun abonné.
Zéro, voilà, ça m'aide à me concentrer sur ma vidéo,
à écrire ce que je veux vraiment dire,
et ne pas me faire influencer, en fait, par les gens.
Je fais quelque chose qui me ressemble,
sinon, en fait j'aurais fait "l'école 23".
Mais j'ai tort.
Je ne peux pas ignorer le fait que des millions de personnes vont regarder la vidéo,
qu'ils peuvent être influencés,
que des jeunes vont peut-être même se dire :
"Ah tiens c'est cool de s'acharner sur quelqu'un de gentil!"
NON, je ne veux pas que les gens s'acharnent sur William,
je voulais juste me moquer gentiment mais bon
quand tu te moques et que t'as des millions d'abonnés,
eh bien ça peut avoir des répercussions que je n'avais pas mesurées.
Le bilan au final,
je suis désolé si j'ai pu blesser William,
si j'ai pu mal influencer les gens.
J'aime bien me moquer gentiment parfois, mais je dois le faire intelligemment,
et surtout mesurer les conséquences.
Si je devais refaire une vidéo, elle serait vraiment différente,
William, je suis désolé.
Comme disait Justin Bieber,
"Sorry"
Maintenant ça va piquer un peu,
mais je vais lire certains de vos commentaires pour vous répondre.
Lecture du commentaire
Alors, ça pique beaucoup, en fait.
Je sais pas si un autre youtuber avait fait la vidéo,
ça serait passé,
je peux pas le dire, en tous cas, je sais que sur ma chaîne ça passe mal
auprès de certains d'entre vous,
du coup, c'est le plus important à savoir,
et ça ne me dérange pas d'échouer,
si c'est pour apprendre de mes erreurs, en fait.
Faire moins d'erreurs à l'avenir,
même si ça pique un peu beaucoup!
Lecture du commentaire
Alors oui, quelques commentaires sympas.
Il y a même un pouce vert, c'est pas le mien,
voilà, donc peut-être qu'il n'y a pas tellement de polémique en fait!
c'est gratuit mdr
J'ai rien dit.
Lecture du commentaire
Alors, j'ai dit ça,
je le pense toujours, je ne voulais pas insulter William,
Et je ne veux pas me transformer en Cortex, non plus.
Pas du tout, c'est pas au programme.
Lecture du commentaire
Alors, en vrai si,
on peut très bien critiquer les gens, il faut juste le faire dignement.
On peut rire sans être blessé.
Lecture du commentaire
Merci la correction automatique!
Alors déjà merci de me défendre,
Et c'est intéressant comme commentaire car je sais qu'Antoine Daniel, de WTC,
ne parle plus des français dans ses vidéos,
parce que son nombre d'abonnés peut avoir des répercussions.
Au fil de ses vidéos, il a pris cette décision,
avec de l'expérience et en fait, j'aurais dû m'imprégner de sa sagesse.
La fameuse sagesse d'Antoine Daniel!
Lecture du commentaire
C'est vrai qu'il faut réfléchir à deux fois avant de poster quelque chose sur internet,
car ça peut avoir des répercussions, et c'est aussi
vrai que je n'aurais pas dû être méchant envers quelqu'un de gentil.
Ça fait de moi "un fdp".
Voilà.
Tu commences à être relou, là...
Ça va, ça va, c'est pas ma faute si... si t'es un fdp.
Lecture du commentaire
Alors déjà, je ne fais pas que des podcasts sur les chaussettes,
je fais aussi des court-métrages, des sketchs,
et mes podcasts c'est sur les moustiques!
Ensuite, c'est vrai que quand je faisais mes vidéos "critique",
en 2011, sur des clips, sur Cortex,
sur tout ça, ça passait plutôt bien.
C'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui, sur mes vidéos comme le clash des Lopez ou William,
je vois les commentaires :
"Non, laisse la critique aux autres,
ça n'a pas sa place sur ta chaîne."
Alors qu'en fait je fais ce que je veux
et au contraire je trouve ça riche de proposer de la diversité,
c'est quand même dommage d'avoir des millions d'abonnés et de faire la même chose
"Les chaussettes 1", "Les chaussettes 2", ''Les chaussettes 3''...
"J'sais pas si vous avez remarqué, mais j'ai toujours une chaussette qui disparaît."
parle lui en français
Superbe conseil de drague déniché par Seb la Frite, ça marche très bien.
la vraie question est...comment est tu tombé sur cette vidéo.y a t-il un message caché ?
Ah, vous m'avez eu!
Je suis démasqué,
je cherche des conseils en séduction!
-Bonjour, je m'appelle Cyprien, j'ai 27 ans, et...
-Désolée, je suis pas intéressée.
Même les portes-manteaux me recalent, putain!
Voilà, c'était mes excuses auprès de William,
Je voulais me moquer gentiment,
et ça ressemblait à de l'acharnement.
En tous cas j'ai vu que sur ta chaîne YouTube, tu le prenais plutôt bien,
et je trouve ça très fort de ta part!
Je regarderai quand même tes prochaines vidéos,
et je n'en parlerai pas!
Je ne dirai pas un mot.
Merci quand même à ceux qui me soutiennent,
je travaille sur des prochaines vidéos,
et je vous dis à bientôt!
Ciao!!